definimos a una buena palabra como la
secuencia de letras que consiste sólo en
las letras a b y c y algunas de estas
letras puede que no aparezcan en la
secuencia y además que la letra nunca
esté inmediatamente después de la letra
b la letra b nunca está inmediatamente
después de la letra sen y la letra c
nunca esté inmediatamente después de la
letra la pregunta es cuántas buenas
palabras de siete letras hay y bueno
aquí quiero mencionarte algo lo más
importante de este problema es el tener
esta oración la letra a nunca esté
inmediatamente después de la letra bien
es decir que tenemos una letra be para
que sea una buena palabra solamente le
puede seguir una misma letra benz o una
letra c
la otra oración dice la letra vez nunca
está inmediatamente después de las
letras m es decir que si tenemos una c
solamente le puede seguir la letra c o
la letra i por último dice la letra c
nunca está inmediatamente después de la
letra
esto quiere decir lo mismo que si
tenemos la letra solamente puede seguir
la letra
a mis bang o en dado caso a una letra be
y entonces nos preguntan cuántas buenas
palabras de citas letras hay así que
déjenme poner aquí siete lugares para
ver cuántas de estas buenas palabras
puedo encontrar ahora bien todo lo
importante es fijarnos en esta primera
letra esta primera letra no tiene
restricciones tienen tres posibilidades
o ser a o b o c por lo tanto ésta tiene
tres posibilidades sin embargo la
siguiente ya empieza a estar restringida
porque fíjate bien si yo tengo que aquí
tengo una letra am entonces no le puedes
seguir una letra c porque estamos
buscando solamente las buenas palabras
entonces solamente nos quedaría o que
fuera ao que fuera bien si por ejemplo
empezáramos con un ave no le podría
seguir una letra solamente podría seguir
una letra b o una letra c y de igual
manera si empezáramos con la letra c en
este lugar solamente tenemos de dos
opciones sea cual sea la letra con la
que empecemos en este lugar solamente
dos opciones y bueno ahora que nos
fijamos en este lugar sea cual sea la
letra que pongamos aquí solamente vamos
a tener otras dos opciones te das cuenta
si en este lugar en nuestro segundo
lugar ponemos una letra b pues de aquí
adelante para qué
buena palabra solamente de dos o ponemos
una vez o ponemos una celda entonces la
idea es análoga y para este cuarto lugar
lo mismo y para el quinto lo mismo y
para el sexto lo mismo y para el séptimo
lo mismo por lo tanto ya no hay de otra
todas las buenas palabras con siete
letras pues son la cantidad de palabras
que me resultan multiplicar 3 por 2 por
2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 es decir 3 por
2 a la sexta y 2 a la sexta es lo mismo
que 2 por 2 4 por 2 8 por 2 16 por 2 32
por 2 64 3 por 64 lo cual por cierto es
180 más 12 lo cual es 192 solamente hay
192 buenas palabras con siete letras
tomándonos la definición de buenas
palabras que tenemos aquí arriba